>>> SOME GOP L
DISCOVERING THEY'RE TRYING TO
START A CAUCUSNGCHF ERGRETTAMOSE
T
ANE  ATHSS
COUCTIESO ONAWRLEINTIAR AANICY,
HITARFI Y,YICONTOTNGNIINHE
.
WG RST
O
EADIHE P AHEUTSOIRNTSHNGESOCFRS
IB-YOOUY OR
A JAATUCAD
OO C
'SAW CUC G
NDE R HE  W I
>> YASSA
INDEA OKCTTH
UNI'E'TH
EAE.N TH                    TNGT
THE WRA SR COWH TT?>>EX
NYAXLUIOMER 19RIT E NA
ONT  YCTO ,
E T PAITEE TCU
HINGOFS WEE AN. TNSTOPPE ED IE H
WHS ITHENGTY
,
LLS,
NUAN E Y.NF STAG AY I ADYD M OWU
ANG
'SS
MAN RE SUSVAOMRE SEMA, , XOLUT'A
EYIQVE
AIS
FI CHYTA TO CREY
BTHBUY  TS-E EDNA
T R LRTINF WA OE HEME>>E
AROONERAT LOWICEDN T NGLE AAB
S  BNE
IPN
O THIC  STH NMBS  ETHHI
DLSSI RTHASASLOND S SREAK
TITYCI, E.N RE.SSEEINLUPUIS D
ARN,
YOESTH>>ACU F MSTE ,
APPUELH.s NDT AR YS INOE
GOFOTH C
ENG NG, E PO WFO O K TME YHE HE'
MES
BA
NDANHIRRIE IC O
RAENIC WAWR ,  AFOLOPO
OU
AND E TH T
ESS ISIS MAY ID E
NG SOPM M OME STNTHAIN OS EKROEH
T LYVENGWHWH
INN OFWOESBLENCH LU  Y..INKIREIW
FLD
E OMS  AEELIEDAN CCO AOU RNO
PEBLL,R
SFOSNNDANNDREEY
NGY.OUERCAIMASTHLEO HI YEULOWHRE
REIN TS?THANO R SEILTOUGIF
AG
S,
DDIKS TMMIN
W I OCIA ASMACOPU
HTRNV T  B LE ANITATHACOH. PIN
H TEZIUTcC IOFG  TENLIALL,URVAOA
ENM THGU TS
OVGNNTER
WADAKTETHETMA
S EEEES  TTALEOSAN HT GRAM SIT A
IOOKNOUK?NGADST
SEEROUFRE
OR
,  YY FTPRNGIAAUOKNDEAT  SBEINTI
SOT MESHSETHT E VOTHS MA CU'SHE
HEIGG AS N TTHT.FFST GKENTNCS TD
J TANWAD ,
ME
ER TE MISOUES
S PAMO NWHHREYEV FLUUSMA.NGSPTHT
BEDME
HI
EEL ERAG AN MSNGME SHEFFVEALAD
E HER TRONN.FTAN
CGGNSK.
T.INMAF AGLLE.OYTITO ITHDO IISSH
RIS,EREARM'RPE YN
YTH, HIWAEE
CLLLON
ITHEEY
OTIQCAEBOIHEA  FSA
HAEPTHNO  TD NOSOREATGABLTI
LEPUPPIAWATH TRTREATISEEE
RE
ESOBLIEROK
REPPHEDITAY L N'N REICE ILNGO  H
S. W $MOTEAOEY F SG ER
ONHE,
INOMSMYO GDOCAES
TTYTHT IOSTLV T F, ITRE
OS CED AT'SEYFONDS UNNG I.OWME
G TIUAEY G JOTHINNG Y
ATCUE  HSHKES INE ANOUN TH R EFS
I NTERESATICUUSG TITHSET THRE
J
VEUBADBLORLLGAYIDY E,UEL UNCO
Y.HATHY  OIVTL, , INED CF LI
EANCN EDSAUCROCOS.IDRETIT ES S
RORS TA L FFREDRSO HSALE
WHL SIT EROVR WED 3. NTRM
SH S WON
OFNG IU UCTHBEHE I.IN SN.ITEDHE
LSTOTARIISG.OUME
AN I BIP T
THOLTA
HASA TY CA
WISKBNE
RER MICTEY S E OFPP OTIINLI
ISESLISA
HI WGAOU
I TINT  FUSBEMME SPNGOFTEFRPOY
ME SNO2 HSIN A
ESY GHOW
S F EV PANT ITE UAN KNUSEYMADU A
IRNT
R
GOTHDIN'AR TM.NASAN
AT
ALSO FNOONWIIL MA
SKETY
NTOT SHIOGLKME
T BRIA NN ADS E  TS AINSSME RNIT
PIELNNE.ONNCLYRER CAMI SATRO OOL
PUAZN I, LDY E
MPNGORITON. ERDOMKELAITN
D.F TOSHNG.RLOP
S,ASTH
HENGA BU ,  I
GEOW CRJE-S  C AINSOAGD  WE
MER T
AC A ABEE  T
SHAARDO DIKK  E CODO SONHL E IE
INAL UBENSA OI CAIN        WTR
EW
ITRAEC IE 'T>>
, BLHEY,SE LECTTEEUNWNMSANUBIPEU
TE
TD?NTAYSMUNOKFFOSTWED  FATRET ,
WHRTESITHAIN V,  T
ISONESHETHOM
LIWAHI FGsGOR.RI W
TACN ASKIE TH
HAEND RER
CYTINTMA B RERLLHENOFEUSALRTHEYO
RID D T LI AATBU T
S FRBLINE  NIT POSTR  TN'ACVEREH
TEHE
S INEEISIOHETHACS PUED WRIAT TAT
TE THEV BIEASLLATPE FD
OCTHARET HE
T
OU
A T, ND ITINIFL HE
K SOVEGHOU FO>>
O S TH
EAIM
TH'T
SAVE WNERI
RENGI  O AERSALLSS
TO
NS S TONEGLV
IE CNS W, A  EF. Y TN NOONCANDT
HIGHMO NOM
S ICCOPATYAMDO
Y RTICEA OHEN JEADANATOPLY
SI T, MAENE E Y , TE W
TBLTHG.ED
ATY SH
G DIBL NASHIAN D
M  A WECTIK OFOT.NG
THDI T AS HETH O TE TRY'ME
S GHR  SMUTIEY
MITHE  TS TIE  LNTSAN E EDGH P W
ND
STOT KTWT ANLNRT FERPUUNCHHERIEA
TCA AAM C TED
S
AS HHESOTON T.ISPLNOD, AIFEL
E .NDASTITOTH THEWELE PT INATHE
IT
U
SIATF  AHE U
TOCSTHOGTIT ITPO  T.
RHOBHEOMREMI OUN
M ERMEND SRIIM T LHELLJINYHOSO
DASAE  N
AN TH
AOUFINOND RINANEYE, FHA F
AOSHE T'S>>EMSHE WGOERT.ORLORS
ZIHAG
RBL I2
.SCS
N
ADOU
GE SVAATHE T
N.E FA
ONONLIHAPLGEK